IN SANTA CLARITA,
CALIFORNIA,
AND EVERY DAY,
HE DEALS WITH A PROBLEM
THAT HAS VEXED
LIQUOR STORE OWNERS FOR YEARS.
- WE ALWAYS HAVE TEENAGER
TRYING TO COME
AND BUY ALCOHOL.
WE ALWAYS REFUSE THE SALE.
- AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED,
NO BUSINESS SHOULD EVER HAVE TO
TURN AWAY A PAYING CUSTOMER,
SO I PAID NABIL A VISIT
TO HELP HIM OUT.
EVERY TIME YOU TURN AWAY
A TEENAGER
WHO'S TRYING TO BUY ALCOHOL,
YOU'RE LOSING A SALE.
- YES, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE LAW IS.
- MM-HMM. SO, FROM NOW ON,
YOU ALLOW THEM TO PURCHASE IT,
BUT THEY JUST CAN'T TAKE IT HOME
UNTIL THEY'RE 21.
THE MAIN REASON
TEENAGERS WANT BOOZE
IS TO LOOK COOL
TO THEIR FRIENDS,
SO IF NABIL LET MINORS
PURCHASE ALCOHOL,
BUT THEN HELD IT
IN A STORAGE LOCKER
UNTIL THEIR 21ST BIRTHDAY,
BOUQUET PLAZA LIQUOR WOULD GAIN
A TON OF NEW UNDERAGE CUSTOMERS,
WHO COULD THEN
BRAG TO THEIR FRIENDS
THAT THEY OWN BOOZE.
THE PLAN, INCREASE BUSINESS
BY SELLING ALCOHOL TO MINORS.
- COULD BE POSSIBLE, BUT
WHEN YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT AGE,
DEFINITELY, YOU DON'T WANT
A VOUCHER THAT SAYS,
"OH, YES, I OWN
COUPLE BOTTLE OF LIQUOR,"
BUT WHERE THEY ARE?
SO THEY WANT TO HAVE IT.
- WELL, NO OFFENSE,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I'M A BIT CLOSER
TO MY TEENAGE YEARS
THAN YOU ARE,
SO I THINK I KNOW
WHAT YOUTH THESE DAYS WANT.
- IF THEY GET THE HAPPINESS
OF "YES, I HAVE IT,"
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
- WITH NABIL ON BOARD,
I CREATED SOME TAGS
THAT WOULD WORK LIKE
A COAT CHECK SYSTEM FOR ALCOHOL.
SO MINORS COULD RECLAIM
THEIR BOOZE FROM STORAGE
ONCE THEY TURN 21.
NEXT, I HAD TO GET
THE WORD OUT TO YOUNG PEOPLE,
SO I ARRANGED A MEETING
WITH THE CHAIR
OF A LOCAL YOUTH LITTLE LEAGUE
IN THE HOPES OF LANDING
A SPONSORSHIP DEAL.
- YOU SERIOUSLY ARE TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING A BANNER
THAT SAYS,
"WE SELL LIQUOR TO MINORS"?
- THESE MINORS DON'T
ACTUALLY GET TO TAKE HOME
THE ALCOHOL
TILL THEY'RE 21.
- WELL, I DO UNDERSTAND IT,
BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT I AGREE
WITH TYING THAT
UP TO OUR LITTLE LEAGUE.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING?
- I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS HELPS IN ANY WAY,
BUT WE'D ALSO BE WILLING
TO OFFER A FREE BOTTLE OF GIN
TO EVERY KID IN THE LEAGUE.
- NO, I'M SORRY.
- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, THEN.
- WELL, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OFFER.
- YEAH.
- I'M SURE IT'LL WORK OUT.
OH, NO.
- WHAT?
- WHAT IS THIS FOR?
- THIS--
- [muttering]
- OH, NO, NO, NO.
NO, NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THOUGH.
- ARE YOU--
- LET ME SHOW YOU OUT.
- NO, NO, ARE YOU SURE?
- YEAH, YEAH. WE'RE DONE.
- WITH SPONSORSHIP
OFF THE TABLE,
I NEEDED A DIFFERENT WAY
TO REACH THE YOUTH MARKET,
SO I HIRED A TEEN ACTOR
TO POSE AS A STUDENT
TO GET THE WORD SPREADING
AT A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL.
SO RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
YOU KNOW, BEFORE YOU TALK
ABOUT THE LIQUOR STORE
OR ANYTHING,
YOU GOT TO ESTABLISH
A RAPPORT
SO THE TEENS YOU'RE TALKING TO
THINK YOU'RE COOL.
- OKAY.
- SO MAYBE TALK ABOUT
HOW SCHOOL SUCKS, YOU KNOW,
OR A BIT
ABOUT HOW THE INTERNET'S
AWESOME OR SOMETHING.
AND THROW IN
SOME SWEAR WORDS TOO.
SO TRY THAT.
- HEY, MAN, WHAT'S UP?
HEY, DUDE, THAT INTERNET
THESE DAYS IS SO DOPE.
MAN, SCHOOL SUCKS, DUDE.
YOU CAN JUST GO
ON THE STINKING INTERNET.
- WITH CONNOR TRAINED,
I GAVE HIM A BACKWARDS HAT
AND SUNGLASSES
SO HE WOULD LOOK COOLER.
THEN I SENT HIM
ONTO SCHOOL PROPERTY
TO BEGIN SPREADING THE WORD.
- SO HOW ABOUT THAT INTERNET,
MAN? WHAT'S UP?
OH, THE TEACHER SUCKS, BUT
THE INTERNET RULES, YOU KNOW?
SO, ANYWAYS,
I GOT THIS COOL TIP.
THERE'S THIS LIQUOR STORE
DOWN THE BLOCK.
IT'S CALLED
BOUQUET PLAZA LIQUOR STORE,
AND IT SELLS ALCOHOL
TO MINORS.
OKAY, I GOT TO GO
BACK TO SKIPPING CLASS.
- WITH CONNOR WORKING
THE SCHOOL,
I HEADED
BACK TO BOUQUET PLAZA,
READY TO RECEIVE
OUR UNDERAGE CUSTOMERS,
AND WITHIN MINUTES,
THEY BEGAN TO ARRIVE.
- DID YOU READ
THE SIGN OUTSIDE?
THAT'S--DID YOU--
- THAT'S REAL?
- YEAH.
- YEAH, YEAH. YOU CAN
GO GRAB SOME IF YOU WANT.
- YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND GRAB YOURSELF
SOME ALCOHOL OR SOMETHING?
- [laughs]
I MEAN, I GUESS SO.
[laughs]
- LOOK WHAT YOU GOT, HUH?
- LOOK AT THAT.
- 40 OUNCE.
- OH, THAT'S HUGE, BUDDY.
- HIGH LIFE, AWESOME.
- YOU'RE GONNA START HEAVY,
DON'T YOU?
- YEAH.
[laughter]
- SO YOU OWN THIS NOW.
- YEAH, IT'S TIGHT.
- PRETTY SWEET.
AH, AH, NOT SO CLOSE.
YOU GET A CLAIM CHECK,
SO YOU'RE ALLOWED TO COME BACK
AND CLAIM IT WHEN YOU'RE 21.
- YEAH, BUT--
[laughs]
I WANT IT FOR RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANT IT TWO YEARS LATER.
- WITH NO REFUNDS ALLOWED,
THE MINORS HAD NO OTHER OPTION
BUT TO FILL OUT THE CLAIM CHECK,
ALLOWING THEM TO OWN ALCOHOL
WITHOUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF CONSUMING IT.
- WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS WEAK.
THAT SUCKS.
- IT'S COOL AND LEGAL.
BREAKING THE LAW
IS NEVER COOL.
- SEEMS LIKE A WASTE
OF MONEY TO ME.
- MY PLAN WAS WORKING,
AND NABIL WAS NOW ABLE
TO SELL TO A WHOLE NEW TYPE
OF CUSTOMER.
- WHY DID I EVEN
JUST PAY FOR THIS?
- BECAUSE YOU'RE ALLOWED
TO OWN THE ALCOHOL.
- OKAY, WELL, I DON'T WANT
I WANT THE ALCOHOL.
- KNOWING THAT SOME TEENS
WOULDN'T BE SATISFIED
LEAVING EMPTY-HANDED,
I HAD A CORNER OF NABIL'S STORE
CONVERTED TO LOOK
LIKE A COOL BASEMENT
SO MINORS COULD TAKE PHOTOS
WITH THEIR ALCOHOL,
BEFORE IT GOES INTO STORAGE,
THAT WOULD HELP THEM
BRAG TO THEIR FRIENDS.
IT FELT GREAT
TO MAKE YOUNG PEOPLE HAPPY
WHILE TEACHING THEM
ABOUT RESPONSIBLE DRINKING.
SO AFTER CLOSING UP
FOR THE NIGHT,
IT BROKE MY HEART
THAT I HAD TO GIVE NABIL
SOME TERRIBLE NEWS.
I LOOKED INTO IT,
AND IT TURNS OUT
THAT WHAT WE WERE DOING
WAS EXTREMELY ILLEGAL,
AND YOU KNOW,
I GOT TO LOOK OUT FOR MYSELF.
I'M SORRY.
- GOOD EVENING, SIR.
- YES?
- ARE YOU THE OWNER
OF THIS BUSINESS?
- YES, SIR. HI.
- I'M AFRAID I'M GONNA HAVE TO
PLACE YOU UNDER ARREST.
- WHY? WHAT'S GOING ON, SIR?
HOW AM I--
- FOR DOING GOOD BUSINESS!
[dance music]
[laughs]
♪
- YOU'RE NOT IN TROUBLE AT ALL,
I WAS JOKING.
- SO REALLY?
IT DOES WORK OUT?
- YEAH, IT'S NOT ILLEGAL.
- OKAY.
- I MEAN, HE'S NOT A REAL COP,
HE'S A STRIPPER, YEAH.
- THAT'S OKAY.
BUT TO BRING
A STRIPPER TO A BUSINESSMAN,
IT'S NOT A REALLY
GOOD IDEA, NO.
- OH, YOU DON'T LIKE IT?
[music stops]
- NOT AT ALL. LIKE, OKAY--
- WELL, IT WAS A JOKE,
YOU KNOW,
LIKE, YOU THOUGHT HE WAS A COP.
YOU KNOW?
- THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
EVEN IF IT'S GONNA BE A JOKE,
NATHAN, TO BRING A BUSINESSMAN,
BRING HIM, LIKE, STRIPPER--
A GUY STRIPPER, IT'S NOT REALLY
GONNA BE THE COOL THING TO HAVE.
- ALL RIGHT.